it is true though a very very special
gentleman's dojo very special we are so
excited today because I have to my left
Gary Kennan as usual from Detroit
Michigan and joining us today in studio
one of my favorites great comic great
podcast himself mr. Kevin Christie yep
yeah really yeah comic awesome comic and
today we will be interviewing Gimli
probably my favorite artist DC Comics
also Korean which is awesome came to set
of Sullivan & Son arm he is an immense
talent and we are gonna interview him in
just a few minutes but we thought we
he's a legend he's a he's a legend
that's by the way this is the first time
in our a little uh kind of thingy that
we've had a guest sit in on our like a
guest co-host join us to interview our
guest and Kevin's got a great show on
this network as well which okay awesome
he's on half oh okay he didn't even know
who you were nothing but you cover that
really well and I have to admire someone
who can be like I don't know anything
about you and then soon as it comes on
just like great guy like that's that
Regis Philbin gear where he's not
attorney this guy's got a parent that
makes casserole and he's excited about
impressive um love this guy so Jim Lee
Casey he is a huge artists who DC he had
his own company image for a while came
back to DC is one of the two head
honchos he illustrates for justice
league he's done hush ah Superman just
everything he's unbelievable and you
know as much as I do if not more because
you are and by the way Kevin so i can
introduce kevin properly Kevin did the
artwork for champion my-my our
specialist on netflix right now anytime
i bring it up Gary use any opportunity
when he uses the bathroom he says I have
to go take a champion I thought so but
thank you so much and I saw artwork is
seen in four homes around the country
right now just so you know yeah
absolutely just so you know that that
hard
work that you put into that but Kevin's
don't work for the strokes who else if
you don't out were the kings of leon
I've worked for the New York Times New
York Times Magazine I know this guy's
done it all I've been a fan for a while
to hate Canady k she know it's so weird
it feels it feels the same as if he
meant it like I'm being tricked by your
delivery do you take like a public
speaking class like ice guy I know it's
like it's like when someone says I love
you in a scene you feel it kind of you
know they don't but you feel is best
acting is not in front of the camera I
do correct I do I'm throw a little bit
because I see your beard imma ride to my
ex-girlfriend right it just throws me a
little bit at your bum yeah I'm sorry I
know Jim calls in do you guys want to
discuss any of your as you're growing up
comics you loved comma she got into are
you still in the comics Kevin I know
it's probably interesting I mean I got
me two comics in it I mean more or less
because of gimli like Gimli the first
x-men i bought was a Jim Lee x-men and
that's what kept me buying it was his
art because it was it's it was crazy to
me I probably 13 12 or 13 and I got like
forty dollars from my dad i went to a
comic book store and I bought that's a
healthy sum to go to comic I had yeah
well I die I got paid for like what my
dad was a schoolteacher and I my job for
like eight hours was to watch a bunch of
like shitty kids while their parents
really good the tea all these teachers
had to go to a conference on a Saturday
so I right stayed in the room and make
sure no one died I got forty dollars and
I walked to the comic book store and
about forty dollars for the comics which
was like I got like a graph like we know
right yeah I walked in like shut the
door I know I was a lot of money and I
bought a bunch of x-men and this is when
Jim Lee had probably just started
penciling him and I mean they were to me
they were like mine I couldn't wrap my
head around someone being able to draw
that well right and I didn't understand
what inking was in penciling so in my
mind it was basically all him and they
were like stunning isn't even the word
like at that point around that time he
did this gatefold thing with x-men where
you can
acted the covers all right yeah and it
was like a x-men reboot like x-men vol 2
which he has the best selling comic of
all time yeah in with the Kinect Barry
Marcia which to my head I was like wait
how do you a muzzle uz different pieces
of paper and you put him next to each
other like he was I couldn't like you
know his drawing ability is I mean
honestly it's of like a rip like
Renaissance artists level it's just put
into comic books right his ability is
that artist is incredible and just his
compositional skills my boy like he's
gotten one of the best ever it's not he
is like a an actual legend yeah it's
crazy like I I mean I made a list of
things that I oh yeah absolutely i'm
excited to ask to gary how about you do
were you in a comics is it well no not
really i mean let me just say I played a
lot of sports in high schools I didn't
really have time cannon you know to to
do that i was getting laid a lot and uh
let me just say this boys um being of
imagination I wasn't having its own this
guy's got a good podcast right here on
this network [ __ ] you Nerdist you're not
getting it you're not getting those for
downloads listen um no no I i wasn't i
didn't really know about the whole comic
book role but i remember i did remember
meeting Jim when we were at that club in
San Diego he came he came to show we did
the Sullivan Sun yeah we came out with
his wife came out with his wife lessly
show there was the the night before
fourth of July yeah emer we all drove
down there and that was my first time I
met him I I didn't he didn't come to the
I didn't I was there the night that he
was there that's all been some but I
just remember after meeting him trying
to figure out like like in the bigger
picture he was and all this other stuff
and I'm ever doing research on him
because I remember he was such a big
hero to you so I remember going back and
looking at house like oh holy [ __ ] this
guy is such a big deal in the whole
comic book community was just crazy to
me because I just wasn't I mean I mean
listen Kevin knows and I mean you know
there's a guy named Vito who know I mean
to know so much stuff about it right but
I mean you know for you guys mean that
guy's just a huge deal and when I
finally got to meet him that night it
was then it kind of became clear to me
who he was and I think every decade you
have your you know your Gretzky or your
Hannah or your Brady and I think he's
definitely I mean he is he falls I mean
when you write if you start making the
list of greatest comic book artists of
all time he's in he's on the list yeah
you know he's he falls into that list of
like Frank Frazetta and and Stanley and
like all those people it's like during
his generation he's definitely one of
those guys for sure it's not even he's
first ballot Hall of Fame oh yeah yeah
yeah I mean it's no question I got into
it when I was like in 7th or 8th grade I
was grow up in Pittsburgh and they had
this great comic book store called IDEs
and we used to leave the suburbs which
was the north hills area and go into the
city take the bus down there and we you
know I didn't have weight but like poor
poor bugger i only had forty dollars
that one time that one time but stretch
but I got into todd mcfarlane yeah when
he was illustrating for the amazing
spider-man yeah and uh his gray Hulk was
like yeah what the and I like his spider
web when when like when spider-man would
shoot the web like this the web would
shoot out but then they were like
spirals around wet and it was like this
is the coolest [ __ ] ever yeah who's
talking carlins hands are really
something but then the difference I
always felt the thing with what Jim Lee
was he wears a lot of especially in the
90s a lot of artists I thought got were
getting bogged down in style and his and
so that like the comment like
composition wasn't as good it was just
all about like look at the the gnarly
style you have right and but his Anatomy
was so good it made it made all the
characters look tougher because they
look more realistic even though they
were like fantastical characters right
they looked more light as closer to
human beings so they looked like you're
like that person could kind of exist
like Wolverine aubs like he made sure
Wolverine look like short and stocky and
you're like oh yeah kind of imagine that
guy actually existing which
inadvertently made him wait uh for
looking yeah yeah i gotta agree with you
I think it's a you know uh you know look
when you see like Alex Ross's yeah no
it's like oh that's probably what he'd
look like you see that Superman you know
circa 1950s yeah kind of look you're
like oh my god that's as realistic i
guess as you would get because he's
painting it but Alex rising photo
reverence where's Jim Lee was it that
right yes so terrifying yeah he was make
this [ __ ] up and look I can make up
people nose is like there's that he has
a weird it's probably like a bore
basically photographic memory right
where he just knows exactly what [ __ ]
should look like so when he's drawing is
just like he's he's almost regurgitating
photographs in his brain as opposed to
ross who's looking at a teacher like I
mean it yeah I've seen some of his
models he shoots photos crap and kind of
compose them Ross is also stunning than
crazy but like it's it's a different
gear I think and there's the speech
alexs ross's comics so I remember when
they were coming out they've taken way
longer to show up where's Jim Lee was
putting out comment yeah you know it's
that I met a guy in art school who named
Aaron Wiesenfeld who worked for image
first of all he's the same age as me
where I was like what the how did you
you had a job in comic books already
know anybody was going to art school it
was terrifying but he was like yeah you
gotta do a page a day when I was like
what it's like it's a really hard job
right you have to sit there all day you
have to crank out a really rad page
every single solitary day and you and
it's not like a ton of money but it's
like right like a legit like sit at your
desk all day job and not only just bang
out you know a page but it's like I mean
these sketches these days are so
intricate because if you go in at a
comic book store nowadays you just look
down the before it used to used to be
able to go in used to spin that rack
around yeah and they were like 20 titles
maybe max and now you go in any store
and you just look down this long like
grocery aisle and forever even character
you like like like now what star wars
they have lando calrissian that
Chewbacca they have Princess Leia they
have Darth Vader and they have shattered
Empire and they have Star Wars and it's
just like you can't go in and just get
star wars now you got to get the whole
cachet I guess yeah Superman how many
titles does he have spider-man how many
does he have so you think about the vast
array of all these different comics how
they're kind of in competition with each
other and then you see all the
illustrations that are one-upping in the
aisle and all that stand there all
popping and it's just these gorgeous
works of art and you're also keating
you're not only competing with the
comics on the racks but you're also
competing with
entirety of comic book history cuz no
curfew comic book enthusiasts get into
like one and don't start looking at old
stuff yeah so when I look it's I'm
looking at all the artists and so I'm
like well how are you in comparison to
these people where are you in comparison
to these artists right so I can the
pressure you must feel when you're like
all right let's like I'm we're like hey
you got the job of drawing Batman you
must be like oh [ __ ] my life God or
x-men re and the people that have done
it have been so good to where you're
like okay I guess it's my turn like
people are gonna do I would I really was
judgmental about like let me see your
claws how are your Wolverine claws
because some people would draw some punk
ass like Wolverine closet didn't look
that sharp or didn't look like Gimli
look like butter knives well they were
like two wide at the end like they
didn't they look like swords whereas
like his were pointy and like had this
like like grit on them like leftover
blood and you're like right those are
sweet what just put gnarlier yeah it but
not but at the same time not like Oh God
look at like some guys would get and I
want to name names but some Mars would
get too into the clause where they made
my tattoo gnarly and it was I was just
like okay yeah I get that you're about
the clubs and it has weird balloon arm
like you spent too much time on the
clock I was feel bad in the movies when
like Hugh Jackman is like pulling out
his Wolverine claws but he does they got
sheared off so it's the bones like an in
the origin ones yeah and then it's just
like Wolverine doesn't look that scary
cuz it looks like he has like an ingrown
free ingrown fingernails like jetting
out it's like he's not tough now yeah it
looks awful yeah you know bad Korean
nail spa you do that bit don't you is
that you the nail spa bit or that's
Angela Johnson um but what you were
saying you talk about that the guy Jesus
he's good to you were talking about the
guy he's good too that was a go grab
blonde over there all you know the boom
goes
dynamite clip remember the other you're
gonna call Phi yeah you watch your mouth
Carrie ladies and gentlemen please
welcome to the gentleman's dojo he is
under the weather we still appreciate
him bucking up mr. Jim Lee everybody how
you doing buddy I gotta do it good thank
you so much for calling and I know
you're sick we still appreciate you
taking the time we're not going to keep
you too long but word Kevin christy is
to my left he did the he's done so much
artwork for like rock bands kings of
leon The Strokes he did my cover art for
champion for my last special and he's a
huge comic fan so we have him joining us
as well as Gary cannon and and as an as
an artist that Kevin is we thought we
let him kick it off with the first
question here first first of all thank
you for doing this second of all you're
a legend obviously you know that
probably I hope I every morning when I
wake up I go yeah I mean I that I
honestly hope you do do that every day
like I want I have my question is do you
have a sense of like the ripple effect
that your drawings have had on just like
the drawing landscape of like probably
the world in general that like how many
people have probably decided to start
drawing or gotten really psyched about
drawing stuff because of looking at your
art yeah you know it's interesting you
bring it up because like go to
conventions or store signings a lot of
fans come up and say heck I got into the
arts art director now I work at this
video company because the comic books
that you drew back in the day so that's
actually the highest compliment you know
I think anyone can receive it's not so
much that you're this legend or
something but that the work you did had
some effect on a kid and kind of you
know open their eyes towards maybe a
destiny or an occupation they didn't
necessarily envision before because
that's certainly what comics it for me
when we move to the United States you
know there weren't these big cgi movies
and this is comics or the only place you
could find this kind of level of action
and adventure
and it really you know when we came here
to America i was born in Korea I didn't
know any English and I I'm pretty much
on a % sure that comics was gateway drug
for me to like to learn the language so
i can understand what all these stories
were that was that i was buying time so
classic asian watch TV you read very
nice work gym ya know I made a list like
heaven does have a Christmas list I made
a list of things I learned to draw by
copying your comics I'm gonna read it
very quick Wolverine x-men type biceps
triceps hands fists claws laser beams
perspective via Cyclops's laser eyes
eyebrows wrinkled foreheads cause of
death blow booth but I male and female
butts ABS hair Batman's head and cape
and a bat symbol so that's an amazing
list I every time you mention one I saw
the visual male female but all that much
laughter I was waiting to hear male male
bulge yeah yeah that yeah yeah I'm doing
that more now that I different time
different time you got to get all the
audience's uh Jim I want to ask you as a
comic I on behalf of all three comedians
here um you know they always say it
takes you 10 years to develop your voice
as a comedian arm and you know you go
down the line and you say Aziz you know
his voice you say layer the cable guy
you know his voice as an artist when did
you discern your voice as an as an
artist when did you know that you have
the Gimli look or the Gimli artistry
where anybody could go to comic book
store nowadays and look at the cover of
Justice League or any one of the titles
that you've worked on go on it's Jim Lee
when did you discover your voice oh uh
well mmm good question man uh I think
the style I have though is really the
summation of all the guys I loved
growing up but there was definitely a
moment I think I just started working on
the x-men we're all still looking at a
lot of my am i pulling out the comics I
love and like oh here's this great shot
i can use this for
reference or here's some inspiration for
this splash page or discover and I
realized if I just did that I would
always be known as sort of the clone or
the best guy that kind of did this other
person style so I made it you know in a
very conscious effort at one point it
must have been in the late 80s very
early 90s words put away all my comics
all my reference and just kind of said
there's got to be some inner style
that's just me let it come forth no it's
influenced by all these other guys all
these other artists but you know let let
let me decide as I draw as I'm drawing
there's no more crutches so to speak and
out of that came I think a style that
people kind of recognized as being mine
in the nineties but even then I was very
aware of the fact that a lot of my you
know a lot of artists kind of fall in
this trap where they their Styles never
evolve and change and not that mine has
changed dramatically but over the
decades I've looked at other people that
have come onto the scene and and kind of
made a splash and so I always try to
kind of open myself to and from other
influences and allow that stuff to
inform I work so that even when I'm dry
now it's slightly different proportions
I'm using less cross hatching a lot of
experimenting more with like brushes and
things like that so just you got it you
got to make sure that you're open to new
influences otherwise you know that's the
death knell for for any artist is really
once you establish the style you guys
are talking about there are these
comedians are artists whoever they can't
stop there I mean especially when when
you hit successful with it because
that's the ultimate trap right is that
you become trapped by the success and
you get scared to kind of evolve and
change and therein lies the problem I
noticed at least from my perspective a
lot of your use of like light has
changed over the years where's like the
early x-men stuff was a lot about
musculature where's now there's a lot
more like drama I would say or in like
your use of light and shadow and stuff
like that for sure yeah try to always
mess around with lighting even
proportions is a big thing
I did this cover it was a flash
anniversary where the flash appeared and
all these other covers and I drew
basically an old lodge to a cover I drew
where Superman was kind of shocking
Batman's neck and the flash kind of
shows up in the background he's planning
like peace flowers and everyone's ears
and I fig that code before the cover was
but I drew it I found the original copy
of the original cover and I traced it to
the starting points and while my
proportions are so different that you
know I draw characters a little longer
not as stout and blocky and then even
like the lighting that you're talking
about try to you know again you're
learning new things every day every year
and just Adam to your repertoire so that
you're not necessarily repeating
yourself even if you are taking some
similar angles or covers that kind of
people have seen before there's so many
different ways you can light things and
render them and you know even the first
of the proportions like I was talking
about all those things are very subtle
things that people don't realize they're
seeing when they look at the image that
has a very profound kind of impact on
their enjoyment yeah they seem like
small things but even like putting
combat boot treads on Batman's babe yeah
that's huge like it's usually different
and it makes you didn't go to him
differently and when you when you have
to what when did you make that
commitment to putting the treads on the
boot then when you go down the line or
you like by page 48 you're like God why
did I pick up a guy why did I do this to
myself because I got all the tracks yes
yes yes a lot of those moments watch the
new 52 I had a lot more detail under the
flash of costume Superman's casa Batman
and certainly when I was drawing all
those characters and justice league by
the third issue or so you're like on
what a numbskull the reason why these
costumes are simple because they had to
draw them over and over I do games they
can create super complicated costumes
because they just create it once and
boom they can use it over and over
throughout the game but I feel like and
the funny thing is when I'm drawing
those treads on that I didn't really
realize that that's what people would
pick up on that's the funny thing about
you know working isolation you're just
drawing that because like a I don't want
Batman to slip
rainy rooftops yeah he can no no I run
over so like how does that work because
they're slippery as hell right so like
wow okay I'll create some threads and
and then you create it there and then go
on you know I got to be consistent so
you keep going back and forth and yeah
and then that's what people kind of pick
up on and the funny thing is really was
an afterthought just kind of as you're
drawing the image like oh I can you know
and it's a bit of realism there so it
really changes the whole but it's
interesting something that smokin
changes the whole thing we're like oh
he's tougher like Nero he can run on wet
Street words before you're like I don't
buy this running like that so yeah I
like with those little booties their
booties before and yeah like oh they're
boots all right it's literally the souls
of like loafers and stuff yeah she's
back in the 70s and 80s and that's the
one thing I remember you know one of my
big heroes was uh Neal Adams and you
know he drew everything so realistically
but then the shoes I was like wait these
shoes are slippery cuz I see not just on
rainy rooftops but I gotta ask you how
is you know if you go in any you know
you you go down the street here in
Hollywood magazine stands used to be all
over the place when I was when I first
moved here and now they're they're all
vacated they're all gone and they always
talk about the decline of print the
decline of the newspaper it seems like
comics is the one industry where it
really hasn't affected has the decline
in sales of print affected comics at all
or because I go to comic book store on
Wednesday it's jam-packed and it seems
like comics are like sports on cable
where they talk about the decline of
ratings on television these days but
sports events will be the one that's
impervious are our comics impervious to
the decline of sales is that something
that you would uh you know I think the
overall number might have come down but
because comics are pricier now or more
expensive than they were years ago the
total number of dollars is probably more
robust or help as healthy as ever
digital a part of that as well but yeah
I mean you know when we launched new 52
four years ago we saw huge spikes double
digits in print and triple digits and
dish
so that was pretty unusual given that
most of the print business around us
were disappearing or trying that but I
think partly one like we don't have
we're not like magazines will not run by
advertising I mean we have some in there
but it's really the sales that provide
all our revenue and then we have the
benefit of all these amazing movies and
TV shows that has really just elevated
the superhero mythology into the
zeitgeist so that I mean everyone knows
who these characters are everyone's
wearing t-shirts and everyone's got
these tattoos and so that's amazing
publicity for what we do that's it I
think we could do a better job of
converting the people that love to gains
in a comment the TV shows and movies and
get them into the comic goodness but I
think most people like what's cool about
comics is if you're really into these
characters you know that this comics was
the source inspiration and all stuff
you're seeing on the screen started
somewhere in a story and maybe their
mash ups or alqim automations of
different stories but it's cool to go
back and and and and be the nerd of
nerds can pee that's from issue 2 21 and
that would read me Batman taschen and
someone's ringing the doorbell here at
all so anyway oh um some present so uh
yeah so it's great I mean if things are
going really well and obviously we have
Batman V Superman and suicide squad and
anytime the trailers drop and we see
huge spikes in sales of the of the
underlying the print material we saw
huge spike in preacher sales just from
the trailer that right and on AMC I
think right that yeah so uh it's been
going really great I mean is there a
better time to be involved in in comics
than right now prior to maybe World War
two when the comics were everywhere and
it was so popular but now with the
impact of like you said film and TV and
all that stuff I mean I comics have
never been bigger is that is along the
pantheon of of the decades that comics
have been part of our lives is there
ever been a better time uh yeah maybe
maybe the
early nineties when friends have failed
or crazy through the roof certainly for
compo craters who are making royalties
off those sales but no I this really is
the golden age because so much if you
love this stuff the technology and the
money's there now to bring these to life
in ways that just were impossible before
just we're very chiefly done before and
now you can really see these characters
brought to life so there are met it's
incredible in fact I think there's more
stuff than you could possibly consume at
this point if you're a superhero fan
right I mean you know just stuff on TV
alone is so many hours of the week and
then the comic books on top of the video
games on top of that so yeah it's
definitely the golden age and the fact
that my parents now know what I do for a
living is a big boat is like they go
that's what we're studying all that time
in your room for we just let your really
strange because because you you gave
yourself you know you were studying
medicine you went to Princeton you
studied psychology you gave yourself a
year is that correct yeah yeah so I at
Princeton I was a psychology major there
was no pre-med major but I took all my
prerequisites i took my MCATs and
everything hi my interviews all my
recommendations but i told my parents
like okay i'm really interested in doing
this thing that you know nothing about
comics that no one knows anything about
but it's got a big future someday there
to be amazing limitations and you'll
care then but for now uh let me move in
with you guys so i said i did yeah so
the deal was out I you know give myself
a year maybe I don't know if I ever
expressed that to them but I certainly
told myself that so I just had a sense
of urgency and and talk to other comic
book creators I everyone has a different
origin story but but sometimes it took
five or seven years I don't know if I
could have emotionally kind of what did
that I would like to think I could but
you know I heard it's tricky I heard a
story that Brad when I got into art
center I heard
story that Brad Pitt had been accepted
to art center as an illustration major
and then decided to try acting for a
year Wow yeah that's what i've been told
i don't know how true that is our like
environmental design he was like i'm
gonna give this acting thing a try sure
so you're the Korean Brad Pitt of comic
book welcome we hear about like Jim you
know you're picking recall he goes to
Princeton he's just talented artist he's
a very very Korean by going to Princeton
I went to Kent State University with a
state school I just performed at a
Mexican restaurant last night for 12
people you make me want to sue my
parents it's not fair and it is not
right now you also wrestled though back
in the day I remember you tell me that
right did is that yeah I said in high
school and maybe a year college yeah
very set say domestic they'd say to my
kiss okay even say the word um that's
very uh unique period of my life because
it is a grueling tough sport I don't I
don't even know why people get into it
but for some reason it struck a chord me
like that you would basically lose
weight run yourself ragged getting into
shape and then go on a mat and has
another guy like pound yes but if you're
up to the task of pounding on him and so
um but yeah how will you you guys all
wrestlers or maybe rambling and
wrestling now I I was so I wish I think
this had you come in today we were gonna
grind of grease up and then I'll each
other but that that your plan fell
through him sorry about that i was on
the mud pit is sitting here for no
reason I was on the tennis team which is
actually really Korean in California
yeah well you said that out loud yes Jim
I was the only white guy I gotta ask you
you make your money with your hands do
you avoid certain things do you avoid
like thumb wrestling or doing that alien
stay with it when they do that knife
truck is I'd really like my left hand uh
no no i don't but there was one only one
time in my career that it was very
concerned like aware that like old you
know if I break my hand or something
happens I'm really screwed and that was
the early 90s when was that marvel
and I got an assignment to do xmen
number one and we knew we can do five
covers and x4 said sold like three and a
half million copies and spider-man had
so like two million copies in their
slate the taking that work and sell 5
million plus or something we've got
maybe four sold 5 million etat and
spider-man sold three million a lot of
those I'm crazy number so I knew that uh
I got this gig whatever and but had to
draw it out right and but I knew I guess
something happened so I'm very conscious
of reaching out to doors that swing both
ways with my right hand because if
there's some guy on the other side yeah
and they're running full sprint because
I've done that where they slam the door
like just I just imagine my fingers
getting pushed back into my palm right
and then like if I ran a yellow light I
put my hand like near my head like Oh
off the steering wheel like I don't know
it's weird yeah like I don't know what
that would do like with that idea that
that it wouldn't get mangled or some car
hit me like a wave no engine stopped
doing that because like us they focus on
this you got it you got to make sure
these are at least the first issue Jim
should always wear those like hand
braces like the waitresses at ihop yeah
I mean it's constantly wear those to bed
I would have still drawn I would have
drawn my left hand or or with my mouth
I've seen documentaries for people i
mean it's the talent right is supposedly
in your head it's just that you're your
most used to drawing or expressing your
thoughts with your right hand because
we're coordination yeah it's really your
eyes and your brain and now you with you
being a DC you're on the precipice of
unfolding and seeing all the characters
you draw you know on a daily basis come
to life on the big screen what is it
like to know and I'm sure you know the
story lines i'm sure you've seen maybe
some cuts of things but what is it like
as an artist to see the things you do on
a daily basis that all the sudden to it
as every red-blooded American man is so
excited to see Batman vs Superman and
see what unfolds as we've heard with the
Justice League being rolled out you're
right there in the midst of all that how
do you feel about seeing all your
characters come to life and knowing in
120 minutes they're encapsulating
everything you do and provide for us on
on a monthly basis uh it's an awesome
honor I mean I you know I think of the
characters are created hush was but he
was in a bunch of the video games Batman
Lego and Arkansas I think he even showed
up on the Gotham TV show he's a um so
and then I think gambit is directly
coming out as a movie sometime the next
year or two character co-created yeah
Marvel was chris claremont so um it's
it's it's cool i mean another but at the
same time i didn't get into comics to
see that adaptation come to life you
know the fun I had long you again
decisions I made a long time ago and I'm
going to just do this or is this a
gateway or is this a stepping stone to
directing or doing animation or I said
no no this is my love is comics I love
storytelling I love sitting down
physically drawing these stories and I
kind of decided then and there that
that's what I wanted to be a comic book
artist that said when you see it brought
to life it's amazing I mean you know how
could it not I mean when you have
visualized this stuff most time you've
got it in your pretty good in your head
like oh this is pretty cool like one
this guy uses his powers boom you see it
but then sometimes particularly the
video game space they can go and do
these special effects that are like
almost three-dimensional like these like
rune said you know be it's hard to
describe but I've you know verbally but
they're able to take what you draw on a
2d space and visualize it
three-dimensionally and then you add
sound in and then the ground shutter and
all those other kind of cool things that
you can't really express and 2d
illustrations and they bring it to life
in different ways and it's just it's
another facet it's another way of
enjoying it so yeah I mean look I'm as
big a fan as anyone else so it's amazing
when you see the stuff brought to the
big screen and I'm thankful that it's
able to touch and influenced so many
more people than just the print comics
because it's an easier medium in my
opinion to kind of take in it's more of
a passive thing you sit down you've gone
this journey of this ride
it's it's good for our core business so
yeah I mean how can you not be thankful
and and it's really cool to see that
stuff nice Jim you know it's crazy for
for everything that you've done in this
this portfolio on this huge resume that
you have I know that I speak for comics
you know obviously comics have you know
a goal of what they want what would
fulfill their career whether it's like
you know playing Madison Square Garden
being on the stage or whatever that is
but what what is it that you want to do
that you haven't done yet I mean if
there's anything but what you know
what's out there that you know that you
would still love to accomplish if if
there was one thing yeah wow that's
great question um gosh there's a bunch
of stuff I've already done but will you
know mostly involved my parents like you
know Steve was their time as DV was
gracious enough to be the host for this
korean american magazine and then they
kind of honor me at end of the year and
side my parents there i was a little
kind of you know talk to them and kind
of express how I felt about how their
impact on me and do that in a very
public forum and so that was really cool
to have that kind of moment people all
dressed up alright so the Pacific and
that was pretty cool because I always
fear that when I got into comics like
that would never be a moment where they
would either see that success in me or
that I would be able to thank them in a
public way a man like comics was really
an underground kind of business back
then creators are fairly invisible you
didn't know where to find anyone you
didn't know how to communicate with
these people the pre-internet of course
so I just imagined that I would be
literally living in a house working in
my bedroom and and that would be the
extent of my career and I was cool with
that because that was my passion right
but there was all these other things I
thought about that I thought well maybe
this will never happen kind of thing so
that was cool to do that but beyond that
a lot of stuff i have on my checklist
really don't hesitate to say this but
don't necessarily hinge upon the art
side or the business side of it so like
having you know
loving wife and the kids and being able
to make a living doing what I love I'm
so those are all things I've
accomplished the wife ignites must be
sitting there yeah that's why sure Jim
tell us earlier when they leave you're
gonna say yeah like you gotta have fun
with your back and if you're going to
have a family you got to have someone
that yeah if you're not there are able
to to you know well Gary can't relate he
has five cats I think the typing I've
got I've got cat suit on no we're close
when you when you first hit like you're
your first big check or the money's
rolling in wait and and you still have
the mindset of like being like a
starving artist what was that first
thing you spoiled yourself with real
like you know what his daddy's turn uh
um problem probably uh meant two cars so
i bought a acura nsx today so that was
like a big card I was like 92 I think
it's awesome that was a hot car and
night was a hot car it rivaled the
Ferrari Oh put this back around rival of
my contract and I think was like 62,500
like roaches and in today's money that's
like six hundred thousand dollars yeah
yeah press time very close Steve just
bought a Fiero okay well you know
Pharaoh's look very similar I love you
I'd like those i I'm not a snob i like i
like the fun I had before my daughter
destroyed a total was a BMW 335 diesel
which had low-end great low end torque
handled super well and a lot of fun to
drive nice well can I ask you one with a
so hey Jim what advice would you have
for somebody who's young starting out
wants to be just like you in that in
that same situation like when you're a
comic you're starting out you can look
at other people and say that's what I
want that's how I want to get to it
there's open mics to go to same with a
musician but like how what what advice
would you have for somebody just
starting out that wants to be where you
are right now yeah that's great
another great question um so when I
started out I just uh I just made up my
idea of how what it would take to get in
like why I should draw samples I should
show them I could do the stuff that they
hire people for I'll draw I started
drawing 24 pages and then I would mail
as officer that's a lot and maybe I can
just trim it down to three you know or
six there it kept getting smaller
smaller then I realized I just need to
show them a snippet I did they don't
need to see this 24-page you know magnum
of this kind of great story they just
need to know that I can draw on I could
tell the story and and I would mail out
like 20 packets at a time to all these
small publishers so I could find you
know find addresses of their operations
in the comics themselves so those are
really analog and very time consuming
but i would say looking at the business
now I mean it's all internet right i
mean you can now reach out to your
favorite creators your favorite editors
and pride say eight times out of 10
certainly in comics because it's a
pretty small business make contact with
them and through deviantart com it's a
great site to host artwork on you can
get your artwork shown to a pretty big
audience and then even if you were to
get rejection from the publishers you
could just self publish you just either
write your own stories or you find a
like-minded person online or at a
coffeeshop that's got ideas or comedian
that's good ideas and they said looking
for time to kill because I decide you
know writing is writing and any day I
tell young people just do it just like
create like don't worry about getting
paid for it right away because you're
not going to get paid for it go ahead
and create a strip and and and it's like
working out once you start doing it you
become stronger and better and you learn
from all your mistakes and your your
your first attempts and and then
eventually you get to the point where
you're good and either then you could
self publish or someone will hire you I
mean I I think we're pretty good as an
industry of finding people that have
ability and talent if they want to work
in comics they will get hired it's just
the timing of it there are people out
there that that
have amazing talent that while working
comics that aren't at this point so that
would be my advice um well we're gonna
close this up by asking just three
questions that fans have submitted us
and then we'll we'll let you get on your
way but this first one is pretty
interesting from a zero Rivera he asked
how has Superman and Batman managed to
stay relevant after all these years Wow
um yeah so what 76 years for for Batman
77 for Superman I think if it trick is
that the fact that they are created
within a collaborative shared universe
right this was one carrot one creator
and they never shared those creations
who's to say where they would be the
fact that you basically had generations
of some of the best combo creators
working on Batman and they were
basically adding to that mythology every
every decade you know new costumes new
gadgets new sidekicks rice mythology's
new villains that's what keeps these
characters fresh and it keeps them
timely because everything that's created
it's going to reflect the era that in
which they were created right i mean
there was back in the 40s superman
fought Hitler and and you know and the
Japanese and and and in the 60s as a lot
of radioactive storylines where
characters were getting powers from
radioactivity a lot of the weird
kryptonite's that that emerged in
mythology came during that air because
people didn't understand really the
impact of radiation on people's
physiology right their mindset so let me
saw that the whole Marvel Universe is
traded on that basically that that
fundamental kind of supposition that
radiation can change you in ways so
that's a that's a big part of it but I
think that the key is that all these
great amazing creators every generation
have kind of stood on the shoulders of
the creators before them who stood on
the shoulders are the creators before
them and have kept this enterprise going
forward and yeah I mean I think also
being first
big big impact to the fact that you know
Benton was the first sort of dark
character and Superman was the first
superhero so right those are the two be
and um this is from Alan mattes what was
your favorite book or title to work on
oh uh gosh you know say all-star batman
and robin I you know not everyone loves
it as much as hush but it was my chance
to work for frank miller and Frank you
know as a senior in college in 86 that's
one dark night returns came out 30 years
ago actually next next year 30 years ago
and that was the book that that kind of
opened my eyes to the potential the
medium I kind of got bored with comics
was in college as all these other
distractions good distraction but but
when i saw that book i said wow this is
so different from anything I read as a
kid because you know hand-colored and
the binding of square bound and then the
narrative was just much more
hard-hitting and edgy and you know felt
more like art with a capital A and
that's what really inspired me to
finally take the leap in ticket to
comics because it's something I thought
about jumping into one ever since I was
like 12 years old I just didn't know how
to do it or couldn't pull the trigger
and kind of go against my parents wishes
and do something besides going into
medicine right um this one is from
Carlos Roberto Franco what is the
hardest project you've had to work on ah
price how far better for us too because
I was working was you know my idol I
mean miller and and frank is a great
writer but he's also a great
storytelling great artist so every time
i read a panel description i immediately
could visualize how he would hand handle
it it'd be this big kind of bold you
know in your face black and white image
and and then i was like hot but i can't
do that because that's you know they
hired me not trying to draw this and
then i'd almost have to consciously
think of what I would you know put that
away and do what I would do right which
wasn't as good that's but uh but so
there was a lot of like second-guessing
early on but then once I got past that
kind of initial kind of concern or
hesitation it got a lot freer and a lot
more fun right well it's awesome i do
have any closing thoughts keveth um I
just honestly I do notice and I want to
say this that you can tell by the way
you still draw now and the work you do
now that you're still super fired up
tomorrow yeah and I think and for
someone who's been doing as long as you
have that sky it's a pretty big deal
when you think of the number of things
you've drawn it's thousands and
thousands and thousands and so to be
able just to tell from looking at like a
sketch you put on Instagram that like no
you're still fired up it's pretty
awesome and I think it's you know it's
rare it's rare in any art form for
someone to still be that excited and
it's great it's just great to see you
know that's as extremely kind compliment
thank you more really good person before
we go though do you have your phone on
you by chance I do yes okay I send you
this so I got this no Steve you if this
goes through here go while we're waiting
Gary do you want to say well I we also
know I anyway so I know that uh oh yeah
went through quick was it via email or
no I sent you it via text oh no still
sending are so good I was gonna ask a
gym if you could do us a favor and draw
Steve as a superhero and his superpower
was selling tickets at comedy club okay
yeah that was unbelievable Gary actually
posted up question on this not this
thing on this thing on facebook where
everybody's asking these kind questions
to gym and then gary said to me my
question is for you Steve would you ever
consider doing a sitcom unbearable hey
Jim you know you should do you ever go
to like the third street promenade in
santa monica and there's those guys
they're like designing the caricatures
just like me you should just go right
next to him like draw your own and then
be like ruin the lives you know right
right you should be like here you go
[ __ ] and then just hand them a picture
but again I this is sick dude I I have
thought about that but usually at six
flags are you doing it six legs yeah
those kinds of really good the
Disneyland I people
legit good yeah and and there's a whole
different skill set of drawing like mrs.
I'm not so good Jim thank you so much
for drawing this I just got the text is
unbelievable that is so it is not quite
done my over some details of doing it
while we're talking why have to tell you
my son my son his name is is Kent
actually but but you put some in their
club but but I named my son Kent oh you
said you named him Clarke well no no I
named him Kent but I think you could
teach except you gambling but he I named
him Kent because I grew up as such a
huge fan of the original seven of the
richard donner film and Christopher
Reeve just embodied everything about
Midwestern principles and the way I feel
like a man should conduct himself and
for me when I was growing up selfishly
and I I feel like such a nerd saying
this but I feel like it so it's the
proper when you say this as much as I
love Superman Clark Kent was always the
bigger hero to me because he was able to
do all these things and it was
suppressed those things in just he was
the foil to Superman I just I don't know
to me Kent embodies everything that is
American and I appreciate it and I I
can't even can't even begin to thank you
for drawing that it's not alive I
haven't done the white out yet on it
like I said it's not finished oh that's
an easy correction and then I'm gonna
put the nerd glasses act I and then it
will be no no this is unbelievable
because Superman is everywhere all over
my house actually in my garage because
my wife makes me put it out there but
Superman everywhere um I love thank you
later like oh you could've got me a
drawing of a reporter but said you got
me a drawing no no no my son is named
after this mythological character that
is such a part of Americana and you are
as revered I believe as any these comic
book heroes that we look up to and I
cannot thank you enough for the time you
took to spend with us especially knowing
you're under the weather I just on
behalf all the fans we love your work
thank you so much and I thank you guys
we can't thank enough Jim get get better
soon pal all right take care thank you
anything created thank you I know but
you gotta tell what the you gotta tell
the audience what this is I mean because
so the gym right uh maybe two years ago
he came to set aside
son and he actually watched the show
being Korean he actually did watch the
show and so he he came to set hung out
took pictures of everybody and he gave
me a copy of hush and he drew a sketch
of Batman in it and it like I got to my
car and I was staring at it for a good
10 minutes and then he just sent me a
text of a picture he drew for my son and
it is Superman busting out of the chains
and like literally a single tier is
gonna come out of my eyes it's just
unbelievable knowing that you know just
even as a guy that goes the comic book
stores on Wednesdays and you pick up his
titles and then to know that he was kind
enough to do something like that even
for my kid is just one bloody me what a
great guy creative he is I mean just
like with his hands then you look at you
and your hands are covered in lotion so
he's like this guy is just you dare a
beer great operating things oh really /
power is if you had a conch we could be
the ruiner of moments good God Gary
sorry about that single t really i miss
out remind me so much about the
Holocaust never again listen don't yell
at me can always listen to your podcast
oh there you are the worst well what
yell you would have to go to your
basement so I don't know that well why
did this turn ugly over side of the last
you did this which warm-ups did you look
up to you did this dude I would just
like to say that gimli legit changed my
life is a young person like for real
like that picked up those comics was
like wait I want to be one of these
dudes yeah well we talked comics before
at The Comedy Store Kevin you and I and
the minute that jim committed to this I
said I gotta get Kevin on because I knew
as a comedian and as an artist you would
appreciate this so that is the end of
the gentleman's dojo here today we got
to thank our good pal Kevin Christie
Kevin where can I find you you can find
me on Twitter at Kevin gee Christy my
podcast
called occasionally awesome it's on the
all things comedy network i'm also on
the show masters of sex i was called
success Gary Lukos coming up hahaha
shove is coming up it's fun except i'll
be at the punchline december 28 and 29
he had missed attunity works i'm jim
leyland unites is that a Tuesday
Wednesday I'm gonna be I love those off
nights you are the worse it's rare you
meet a legitimately bad person yeah
absolutely at buddy comedy right huh I
still don't like that I show godaddy
believe check a lot on those off nights
he'll be Kofi track cannon comedy like
all things comedy guys keep the reviews
coming in on iTunes we appreciate it
thank you so much for junior answer the
question if you're gonna do is I come
[ __ ] off Greg that's it ha thank you
take care everybody Co featuring is so
funny